[Music]
[Applause]
bring in dan orlowski do you love joe
burrow or do you love joe burrow
i love
joe burrow joe's my favorite young
quarterback um
you know dad i'll be honest with you man
so obviously call college football for
espn and
um the year that lsu 2019 won the
national championship i had called
a couple of clemson games that year and
i've loved trevor lawrence really since
that freshman season at clemson
called a couple of clemson games that
year and then going into the national
title i was i was trevor lawrence i was
just like i think the kid's absolutely
spectacular and i thought joe was really
good and heisman win all that stuff but
then i did the mega cast
for that game for espn and we were on
the field it was me and mcafee and it
was just a free-for-all
but i remember during that game and then
after that game walking away going
that's the guy about joe burrow i was
like that he has
that rare just super rare ability that
he mentally wants to
just he takes pleasure in taking your
soul on a football field like he he
wants to humiliate you
while also his pulse just never seems to
rise at all and i think it's one of
those things or the thing that nfl teams
just chase after chase after for
quarterbacks but it's so hard to
kind of touch and quantify and uh i said
this
last year there was no young quarterback
that i would have taken outside of joe
burrow besides desean watson um in that
moment and then i sit here today there's
not a young quarterback that i would
take over joe bro under the age of 25
gimme joe bro even justin herbert
yeah yeah and i love justin i think
justin's fantastic he's going to win mpp
of the league at some point what do they
do what's what's what's bro do better
than justin herbert
um i think joe
number one has the ability to never
panic you know we calling poise whatever
he just never panics with the football
and i see a great majority of that with
herbert um but not in the like not in
the way that i see it with joe i think
joe can make
um
more throws that require
a little bit more touch a little bit
more love on them justin's arm is so
powerful and so strong now justin could
do things that joe can't as well with
the arm strength and the athleticism um
i i just i think because of just the
the ability to never panic with the
football is my favorite quality of joe
yeah you start to look at these
quarterbacks and i think it's easy to
forget about joe burrow because he was
playing for the bengals like that you
know that's a cute little story then he
got injured then coming into this season
afc north was packed top heavy it felt
like and then there was going to be the
bengals and then you look up and you go
bengals won the division and they're in
the playoffs but i also wondered bigger
picture here are we being fair to the
job that joe burrow did
that it feels like it's a foregone
conclusion it's aaron rodgers mvp and
then tom brady second
maybe it's joe burrow or jonathan taylor
has anybody been more has
have rogers and brady been more valuable
to their team
than joe burrow
i don't think you could say that they've
been
exceedingly more valuable but i do think
that the fact that the green bay packers
were 13-3 with aaron obviously 13-4
after this past weekend and the one seed
when
you know that and this is why i think
that matt laflore is the coach of the
year and and with respect with the job
that mike grebel has done and and a guy
like nick siriani and zach taylor the
offseason has to factor into the
equation when you're when you're talking
about aaron rodgers in regards to the
mvp
this team lost their starting tight end
midway through the season they played
games with aaron jones they didn't have
their all-pro left tackle they lost
their basically best offensive lineman
outside of bakhtiari and elton jenkins
the reality of that alan lazard missed
games so the fact that aaron rodgers
played at the level that he did and
never hurt his football team
in regards to kind of his impact on that
team and being the one seed given
everything that transpired that's why
like aaron's the mvp for me i agree
joe's been spectacular if it wasn't for
two hall of famers joe's probably in
that top conversation but i don't think
you could put him past aaron and tom
of all the uh coaching vacancies if you
factor in the quarterbacking situation
yeah how would you rank them it's a
great question i think it's the i first
of all denver broncos is is the number
one for me um with you guys
yeah the denver broncos when you guys
sent over the note
um that that was gonna be a question i
was like well that's that's easy it's
jacksonville you know it's trevor
lawrence
and then i started to think about it and
i said well
you know what about denver dan because
denver's got a phenomenal roster they've
got great young skill talent really two
good backs one being very young a solid
offensive line sir tan looks like a
superstar you just got to get a
quarterback right and then i thought to
myself dude you got to play justin
herbert and you got to play patrick
mahomes four times a year you don't want
that job
and then i started to lean towards the
chicago bears because you you know
you've got at least a talented guy in a
year more than likely he's going to be
the most talented quarterback in that
division assuming aaron leaves green bay
um but
the reason i put and then obviously the
new york giants i think the giants have
more talent on their roster than kind of
the situation portrayed it to be this
year
denver broncos are one for me because i
still think that that is a potential
destination for aaron if aaron leaves
green bay
um afc get him out of the nfc and
they've got a head coaching vacancy that
you can kind of
nathaniel hackett pair it together
potential but i just think it's so hard
to build a roster in the nfl around a
quarterback you like the the broncos
already have
95 of the puzzle done now the one
missing piece is obviously a missing
piece but we've got rogers potentially
in the market we've got russell
potentially in the market we've got
baker mayfield potentially in the market
we've got deshawn watson in the market
whatever your opinion on that situation
is and how the league handles it and
then we obviously have the draft so i
know it's easier said than done to find
that guy but we often don't have
veterans entering the market that are
good potentially like this uh i think
second for me would probably be
um the jacksonville jaguars because of
trevor um i just think he's still got
the chance to be a phenomenal phenomenal
player i would then say
um the new york giants would be a close
third i think they could be too i still
think the giants are the giants dan like
it's the stinking new york giants and i
believe there's some young talent on
their defensive side
i would move on from daniel jones i
would move on from saquon barkley easily
and then i put the bears because they
just don't have money in draft capital
you also have the vikings situation
which is interesting a new coach coming
in and you got kirk cousins who gives
you
sort of
it's almost like it's food that that uh
fills you up for about 15 minutes and
then you're hungry after that like it's
really good but then it's like it's not
that fulfilling and you got to pay him
45 million dollars
yeah i was having this conversation with
scott pioli yesterday because i was
saying you know it's a front office how
do you handle it because you know
there's five or six just great guys like
they quarterback wise they are great and
then there's that group of 10 or so that
are good players and if they get a good
play caller and they stay healthy on the
offensive side and they got good
position players skill wise they can
play like a great player but they're
good and how does the organization kind
of
maneuver its way saying we got a guy
that's good when when does the moment
come we gotta chase the great one we
gotta try and find a great one yeah so
minnesota is a good one i forgot so
minnesota the most interesting thing for
me for minnesota with the new general
manager and the new head coach is yes
what are you gonna do with kirk i think
his contract is guaranteed next year as
well
and then and i don't know justin
jefferson at all but i think he's in
bonafide top three guy at the position
potentially top five probably right now
conversation how do you get him how do
you convince him to stay when you know
eventually justin's going to become a
free agent and how do you convince that
player to stay a part of your
organization i think is one of the
biggest challenges for the general
manager
that prescott has been good very good or
other
uh dak prescott's been good this now
that president's been very good this
year he's been very good there's been
moments where he did not play uh to his
kind of standard um injury he did not
maneuver the pocket well he would drop
his eyes against the rush i think the
connection between him and amari cooper
is very much so lacking the reality is
what the tape shows and the numbers say
um
i think that there's two quarterbacks in
the playoffs three quarterbacks in the
playoffs that have an immense amount of
pressure on them
dak prescott matthew stafford and aaron
rodgers um i think aaron's probably
third in that list because i think he's
so at peace with whatever's happening um
i think the amount of pressure on dak
prescott and matthew stafford is
enormous yeah i would throw josh allen
in there too
yeah
this was supposed to be his year the
year yeah i mean josh has had a
tremendous year i agree it's playoff
time you know new england is weaker than
it has been you know if they had seen
him five years ago six years ago i think
the afc is absolutely loaded um
yeah you know like if if i would if you
had told me they had tredavius white
still i would sit here and say yeah
because i think that defense is
unbelievable i still think their defense
is really really really good i don't
think that josh has more pressure on him
than matthew or dak though
yes there's pressure on him but i don't
think more than those two guys
more likely to leave their team russell
wilson or aaron rodgers
i think russell wilson
you know i really do i think we
obviously heard the rumblings last
offseason it seems and mina kimes has
pointed this out many times on nfl live
like it seems like the organization is
going to have to choose russell wilson
or pete carroll yeah um i would go let's
take russell let's keep russell and and
find a new coach but i don't know if
that's what russell wants i don't know
if that's what the organization wants i
just
and i think that you know given what had
happened last off-season and then the
way this season went um
i just think it's it's likely that he
leaves that place i also think it's
likely that there's going to be a lot of
teams that are going to be very
interested in russell um the way that
that things have gone in green bay it's
you know like i feel like i try to go on
in my job and be very convicted in the
things that i say i have absolutely no
clue what aaron's gonna do
i just wonder why would you leave
the nfc north
like i yeah i've already i can plug in
at least five wins it feels like for the
next couple of years
and you've got
as much as he was critical of the front
office that front office knows how to
draft
they
they may not have taken a wide receiver
instead of jordan love but they can flat
out draft and they sort of rival you
know the ravens are always wonderful
so i got that i got the legacy there i'm
i love denver i think denver is the the
sneaky pick because that roster is ready
to detonate in a good way but i i just
look around and go you keep devonte
adams got two running backs
you got your you know offensive line
some defensive players who can make a
difference you like leflore you can deal
with you know the front office like
you know
the only reason aaron would leave would
be things that have nothing to do with
what transpires on the football field
this would have to be i just want to
change the scenery or i want to move
somewhere different or i just i wanted a
different challenge it's different
than the situation that tom had because
tom left new england because of a lot of
what was transpiring on the football
field because of the depletion of talent
where if aaron leaves it's going to be
because i wanted to do something
different i wanted to try something
different in a different space it has
nothing to do with i felt like
opportunity football wise was going to
be greater somewhere else you stan
orlovsky of the mothership you can see
him uh they got monday night wildcard
that's uh the mega cast there uh dano
with meena kimes marcus spears laura
rutledge and uh you can see them daily
on nfl live is there a college
quarterback worth a top five pick this
year
um i haven't seen one dan you know i and
i and i won't dive into those kids
really till like the end of february
early march but i i haven't seen one i
think
top ten
there will be you know this league you
know there will be um you know i think
the kenny picket kit is interesting
because from pitt because of what mac
jones has done this year i mean you get
it and what joe burrow has done now i
don't think he's nearly as good as joe
but you know that that guy that played a
lot of snaps in college and that is a
very smart player and has kind of you
know hardened that leadership skill set
and is mature enough to go into that
locker room and and um is a better
thrower than he is an athlete but a a
good enough athlete and creator i think
kenny pickett is an intriguing guy um
obviously corral is going to be somebody
that is going to be
very much so paid attention to because
of his athleticism malik willis from
liberty because of just the raw special
talent and athlete that he is
um
i think some will go in the top 10 yes i
think this strong kid out of nevada is
going to be one of those to keep an eye
on that yeah yeah
don't know enough about him you know
that's where you're like wait a minute
uh he's going to test off the charts or
it just feels like if somebody's going
to come out of nowhere it might be might
be that quarterback or at least that's
just a gut feeling that i because every
year there's always a riser there's
always
here he comes and you're like wait a
minute and then you realize
you know
then there's just going to be so much
quarterback movement this year man like
i know we thought last year it was gonna
be it and we had a a little bit but this
year i mean you could be thinking of
you know the dolphins could be in the
conversation for a quarterback you're
you're looking at the
um you know what happens with the
raiders and derek carr i'm such a derek
carr fan and i think he's a phenomenal
player but they don't owe him any more
money
who's going to be their head coach you
know it's just like
you know there's
their car can have movement what happens
in cleveland with baker mayfield what
happens in pittsburgh
um
you know what happens in indianapolis
what happens in houston there's just so
much potential movement at the position
man uh obviously you are here to show
off the guns
i just got done working out man i
wouldn't call them guns dude
let's see let's see let's see what you
got let's see what you got there look at
this dan look at this
you know suddenly that's i don't feel so
bad
dan this is someone who like i've worked
out relatively fairly since i was like
12 years old
it just didn't happen man it just
this is like someone who works out
really really hard yeah i remember you
know being like in the nfl my first
couple years and i would hit the weight
room as hard as anybody just because
that's you know something i i was
brought up work out about this net and
the guys would make fun of me because
they'd be like no one on our team works
out harder than you yet no one looks
worse than you do
and i would sit there back yeah guys i
understand that try to try being the guy
see you're like the before
to brady quinn's after
brady's absolute specimen
i could yeah i'm not even the before i'm
like like like fresh out the womb of
brady
you know just kind of like smushy and
you know why do why does your body look
like that rather than its [ __ ] as an
adult male 1 oh great to talk to you as
always thank you buddy we'll be watching
all right bud thank you so much have a
good day that's dan arlovsky the espn's
first monday night wild card will
feature the mega cast with uh dan and
the rest of the nfl live team mina kimes
marcus spears laura rutledge